foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 our top story an
eight-year-old girl dies and 16 others
are injured after a car crashes into a
primary school in Wimbledon very sadly
one of the children an eight-year-old
girl died at the scene
our thoughts are with her family at this
incredibly difficult time
also tonight we travel to Mintz to meet
the president of Belarus an ally of the
Kremlin who says Putin will not try to
kill the leader of the Wagner group
Connor Chapman is found guilty of
murdering Ellie Edwards in a pub on
Christmas Eve
I often to never see another Christmas
again ever in their lives
the making of
iter we have a special report to find
out if you can train a chat bot to
become a journalist
Twitter threatens to sue Mata after the
Facebook parent company launches threads
and 30 million people join
and it gets heated at headingley as
England Bowl Australia out on the
opening day of the third ashes test
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
front pages in our press preview from 10
30.
[Music]
good evening it was the moment everyone
feared today the news that an
eight-year-old girl died after a Land
Rover crashed into a primary school in
Wimbledon in South West London it
happened during an end of term party at
the private school where tables and mats
had been set up outside for the children
16 other people have been injured 10
were taken to hospital the driver a
woman in her 40s was arrested at the
scene
the incident happened in Wimbledon just
before 10 o'clock this morning Emergency
Services were called to the study Prep
School an all girls private Primary
School in Camp Road after the car
collided with a building within the
grounds our correspondent Rachel
venables sent this report from there
it took only seconds for an end of term
party to turn to utter tragedy but just
before 10 this morning a Land Rover
plowed across the grass into a building
at the study Prep School a a private all
girls primary
police ambulance the fire brigade even
the air ambulance raced to the Sea
16 people were hurt and one little girl
lost her life
our officers along with colleagues from
other Emergency Services provided first
aid to a number of people who had been
injured
very sadly one of the children an
eight-year-old girl died at the scene
our thoughts are with her family at this
incredibly difficult time
an appalling end to the year at a quiet
much-loved School a young child on the
last day of term celebrating the end of
term with friends was also tragic in the
impact it's going to have on a huge
number of other young children and
family and friends across the community
very much a Wimbledon school so lots of
Wimbledon families will have children or
had had children here indeed many years
ago my own daughter went here and it's
built a sense of community not with only
within the school but in the wider
Wimbledon area and so the effect tonight
will be felt very deeply
as the tow truck arrives to take the
Land Rover away we know the police are
continuing to scour the area for
evidence and to try and work out what
happened here as all day we've seen
injured and traumatized schoolgirls
being led away from the school holding
tight onto the hands of their shaken
parents this has horrified an entire
tight-knit community
I mean I'm just shaking I can't believe
this has happened like five minutes down
where I live
and I just understand why it's
and children of all people as well
in a statement the schools say it's
still far too soon to fully understand
what happened but we are well aware of
these significant impact this Dreadful
event we'll have on our pupils and their
families their welfare remains our top
priority and we will be doing everything
we can to support them especially those
who suffered injuries
police were quick to say they weren't
treating this as Terror related and a
woman in her 40s has been arrested on
suspicion of causing death by dangerous
driving as the school Community comes to
terms with what happened a family faced
the unimaginable loss of their
eight-year-old daughter Rachel Venable's
Sky News Wimbledon
it's less than two weeks since the head
of the Wagner group yevgeni pagosian led
an armed column of his mercenaries
towards Moscow only for the short-lived
Rebellion to end as quickly as it had
begun the agreement to resolve the
Mutiny was for progosian to go into
Exile in Belarus but today the Belarus
President Alexander lukashenko revealed
burgosian is now back in Russia
lukashenka was speaking to journalists
including our Moscow correspondent Diana
magnet in the Minsk Palace of
Independence and Anna joins me now down
extraordinary to be in the room with a
lukashenko what was that like and did
you believe what what he said
well it's not often that we get
invitations to report from Minsk or
visas uh Alexander lukashenko the
Belarusian leader doesn't really like
the scrutiny of the international media
most of the time especially when it
comes to the rights of his own citizens
but he does seem to enjoy and rise to
the occasion when he has something to
say and right now he's got plenty to say
on a number of topics the transfer of
tactical nuclear weapons to Belarus and
how he says if Belarus is attacked he
will not hesitate to use them with
targets already defined the fact that
he's hoping for a victory for Vladimir
Putin his closest Ally in Ukraine and of
course as you say the one topic that I
think was of most interest to all the
journalists around that Round Table the
latest on Wagner where they are where
their forces are going to be based and
what yevgeni Prego is up to and where he
is and to be honest do I believe what he
had to say yes to a certain extent I
don't think pregozian is in Belarus
let's just take a listen
this was the last we saw of Wagner boss
yevgeni pregojin leaving the Russian
city of rostov ondon after telling his
men to call off their march on Moscow
and apparently heading for Exile in
Belarus
but the man who brokered that deal
Belarusian leader Alexander lukashenko
told a select bunch of journalists today
the pregosian was still in Russia all
criminal cases dropped all possessions
returned even as photos of the contents
of his Saint Petersburg Home Gold Bars
wigs and all flooded the internet
if he is still in Russia do you see the
any possibility of a rap Rushmore
between pre-godian and the Kremlin or do
you see ties there fundamentally severed
yesterday afternoon I talked to him on
the phone and we discussed what PMC
Wagner was going to do he told me one
thing we will work in the name of Russia
for the benefit of Russia and we will be
fulfilling our duty until the end in the
way that it was agreed by certain organs
of power so he is free what happens to
him next well things happen in life but
if you think that Putin is so malicious
and vindictive and that he will to say
in plain Russian whack him somewhere
tomorrow no this will not happen
when you put it as for these satellite
images of a military Camp not far from
Minsk rumored to be under construction
for The Mercenaries use Mr lukashenko
said he'd offered Wagner the facility
and they'd said no and there was still a
lot to work out
the Kremlin today said it does not track
yevgeny pregozian's whereabouts but it
does seem extraordinary that a man that
President Putin not two weeks ago
branded a traitor should be free to come
and go in Russia as he pleases and
apparently not quite ready to take up Mr
lukashenko's largest
to ask the Belarusian leader was
remarkably
after the wide-scale arrests which
followed his people were reluctant to
give much away
I wondered how you feel about Wagner
mercenaries coming to be based here no
Collins I'm sorry
is that because of the political
situation oh well not time I'm sorry
what about tactical nuclear weapons you
worried about those being in Belarus
I don't know what to tell you it's
politics
what can we do
I don't want to touch upon this topic
I'm sorry
these are countries where people are
jailed for a tweet and yet the man who
marched on Moscow walks free and it's
still not at all clear how and why he
gets away with it
Sky News Minsk Belarus
the father of Ellie Edwards who was shot
and killed on Christmas Eve has said he
hopes her killer never sees another
Christmas Connor Chapman has been found
guilty of murdering the 26 year old
outside a pub on merseyside our
correspondent enzyme Rashid was at
Liverpool Crown Court
this was nothing less than a cold callus
calculated attack just 10 minutes before
Christmas Day
12 bullets from a lethal submachine gun
indiscriminately fired into a crowd of
people outside a pub injuring five and
killing one 23 year old Connor Chapman
today convicted of murder
Ellie Edwards a strong caring innocent
woman was not Chapman's intended target
she was a wholly innocent bystander
caught in the middle of petty gang
rivalry two bullets to the back of her
head meant there was no chance of
survival
her family have been present at court
for every day of this trial Justice for
Ellie so it's always been about I hope
them to never see another Christmas
again ever in their lives he has not
looked at me once because he's a coward
and that's exactly what he is I mean I I
couldn't care less about him not even
I'll never ever mention his name and
he'll be rots in Hell throughout the
trial Connor Chapman denied it was him
who drove a stolen Mercedes to the
lighthouse Inn that night denied it was
him who pulled the trigger he said he
was at home wrapping Christmas presents
it's uncomprehendable that's that
somebody would think that they could get
away with
um leaving the house possession of a gun
go into a pub that was packed and then
discharge a submachine gun into a crowd
Chapman did manage to seriously injure
the men he was targeting Kieran selkeld
and Jake Duffy both from a rival estate
Connor Chapman was out to kill he
arrived in wallasey just before 9 pm and
waited in his car just over there with a
clear and unobstructed view of the Pub's
entrance he was out here where Ellie
Edwards came for a smoke just four
minutes earlier to convict the man
responsible the evidence was
overwhelming red gloves he wore when he
carried out his attack covered in his
DNA along with a bullet casing found at
the scene of the murder the defendant
then seen ruffling his long hair and
dropping the scorpion gun as he walks
towards his friend's house just 12
minutes after the shooting
helping him was his criminal Ally Thomas
Waring today also convicted for his part
in assisting a murderer Ellie Edwards
was happy celebrating on Christmas Eve
an innocent woman whose family say she
had so much yet to give we've been
pulled through hell
and it's now a new chapter it's a new
beginning for our family
in the man Rashid Sky News Liverpool
artificial intelligence has rather
quickly moved into our lives with the
emergence of chat Bots could artificial
intelligence actually revolutionize the
workplace and could some roles be
replaced that's the question our science
editor Tom Clarke has been considering
as he set out to create an AI journalist
capable of doing the job of a sky
correspondent
well the current hype around artificial
intelligence has its origins in Silicon
Valley the technology and its
applications have been quietly coming of
age in some unexpected places pretty
much everyone agrees AI is going to
transform Society including the jobs we
do but how far and how fast is that
going to happen so we set ourselves the
challenge of seeing if we can get an AI
to do my job and I've come to Trondheim
to meet someone who can help us answer
that question I was quite surprised that
am I only the one using this because I
felt it's really increased my
productivity anyone can prompt chat GPT
to write a news report but we wanted to
do what others haven't done and make the
AI prompt itself to be the journalist
Chris built our AI reporter on a
backbone of python computer code and
chat GPT it gathers story ideas using a
crawler software that scans the web for
the latest news and video
to simulate the thought process of a
reporter to chat GPT agents work
together first an AI reporter pitches
what it thinks are the best stories then
an AI editor critiques the reporter's
work it's going to create eight
different ideas so we can probably see
those ideas popping up soon
yeah you can see the idea now about 20
minutes after we set it running a news
article is ready this is it Heatwave
havoc
unraveling the UK's escalating Health
crisis amid Rising temperatures so
there's some pretty bold claims in the
article about the increase in heat waves
the direct link to increase you know
illness and death can we take those as
fact uh no you really shouldn't do that
because the model is kind of trained on
that it always wants to give a good
response right but if you can't really
find a good response it's always gonna
make something up that is kind of what
we call hallucinations
and in my business what you'd call
misinformation or lying but perhaps its
toughest challenge is producing a TV
report and once it got the reports are
saying as climate change remains
unabated being prepared is our best line
of defense against the blistering
onslaught of a hotter future wow its
ability to write short Punchy sentences
suggest where pictures should go the
fact the pictures are relevant to what's
going on that's that surprised me we
associate scenes like this back in
London the next task is to use different
types of AI and a human volunteer to
give our reporter a personality
our producer Hannah lending her face and
voice to train an avatar
I have been trained using a four-minute
video clip of how
it's pretty convincing to me yeah that
would film me a few days later our
reporter has a Persona now that process
is complete I can say whatever text you
type in all it remains is to feed our
Avatar the AI reporter's script
so has our experiment worked in my next
report we'll put that to the test
Tom Clark Sky News
well the AI reporters news story will be
revealed tomorrow and we've got a
special program at seven o'clock on
Friday night here on Sky News exploring
the impact of AI on the workforce in the
UK and Beyond that's AI future a special
program Friday night from 7 pm
there's more pressure on Rishi sunax
government tonight with the prospect of
another by-election Parliament standards
Watchdog recommended an eight-week
suspension for the former Tory deputy
chief whip Chris pincher over groping
claims claims that helped oust his old
boss Boris Johnson a year ago Skye's
political correspondent Mari Aurora
reports
in what has been a safe seat for the
Tories for over a decade Tamworth is now
in the eye of a political storm it's MP
Chris pitcher was today found to have
groped two men while he was deputy chief
Whip and his constituents have had
enough I just don't think he should be
there at all you shouldn't be allowed to
talk to other people unless it's
consensual regardless of the situation
gives us a bad reputation
Mr pincher quit his government role last
June after being accused of assault at
the exclusive Carlton Club in London
where he'd been invited to speak now a
report by the standards commissioner
says his conduct was profoundly damaging
it describes how he groped two
individuals while intoxicated and his
physical contact with those individuals
was unwanted upsetting and deeply
inappropriate the report also quotes a
witness who claims the ex-tory MP was
beyond drunk they say I took the deputy
outside and asked him to go home because
I thought he was embarrassing himself he
refused the witness then says another MP
saw Pinscher grope a civil servant
if the eight-week ban is backed by MPS
it could trigger a fifth by-election for
the Tories but the education secretary
didn't want to be drawn on his future
I have no idea about the Chris Prince
report what I do know is I support the
Privileges committee I haven't read
their report yet but I do support them
Mr pincher said he is conscious of the
effect the Scandal has had on his family
and he once again apologized to all
parties involved but the labor party are
calling for him to quit immediately
if he doesn't do the decent thing I want
the government to schedule the time for
us to debate and vote on this as soon as
possible because real people need to
know that we do take action Mr pincher
in July of last year Mr pincher was
asked by Sky News about the allegations
but refused to comment could you just
tell us a bit about what happened at the
Carlton Club back in June
the scandals surrounding Mr pincher led
to the downfall of Boris Johnson after a
wave of MPS resigned
now Rishi sunak looks destined to
continue to put out the political fires
left burning by his predecessor Mari
Aurora Sky News Westminster
elsewhere in politics secure Stamo was
heckled during a speech setting out the
labor party's policies on education
should they get into government the
protest Group Green New Deal accused
labor of you turning on a range of
issues including the climate housing and
student debt
or before the interruption to care was
laying out his plans which include
ensuring more children study sport or
creative subjects until they're 16.
he also wants to include speaking skills
in the school curriculum and said labor
would embed digital literacy to
introduce a curriculum fit for the
digital age he's been speaking to our
political editor Beth rydby
the mission on opportunity which the
next Labor government will deliver Kia
stoma
in Medway to unveil the fifth and final
mission of a future labor government I
promise you this whatever the obstacles
to opportunity wherever the barriers to
hope my labor government will tear them
down pledging to break the class ceiling
a political priority and a personal one
too I see this Mission as our core
purpose
and my personal cause
to fight at every stage for every child
the pernicious idea that background
equals Destiny but in the background
accusations from activists
but he's going back on green investment
plans will you just let me finish this
handling the hecklers before getting
back to his mission that a child starts
in life won't determine where they end
up but clear too he won't back up
promises with big increases in public
funds will you commit to more investment
for schools and education ahead of the
next general election we can't hide from
the fact we're going to inherit a really
damaged economy after 13 years of
failure can't hide the fact that we're
going to inherit failed public services
and we have to take hard decisions
leaving a hard reality for pressed
Public Services the point I'm trying to
make to you is that it has to be
Evolution not Revolution because you
simply don't have the resources to
deliver it fast well look is that fair
though I've not pretended that we can
snap our fingers on this and we're
absolutely clear that this is our
priority we can make the changes one of
those changes to bring the standards of
private and state schools closer
together by when well as soon as we can
and that's the first time of the labor
government takes two labor governments
takes a generation by when this is
intended to set out what I would hope to
have achieved in five years of a labor
government maybe a little bit more
attentive promise for a labor
government's fast term but those in the
sector from schools to vocational
colleges all too aware of the pressures
at play I think we're all realists to
understand that it's going to be
difficult because there isn't money and
we're in a long queue with lots of other
people but the fact that education is
starting to come square and Center is
really encouraging
definitely be the judge of that the next
phase of his plan for power turning
these missions into concrete pledges
later this year Beth Rigby Sky News
Jillian in Kent
Stephen Lawrence's mother says she's
immensely distressed by the crown
prosecution Services decision not to
charge for retired met officers who were
involved in the botched murder
investigation
Stephen Lawrence was murdered in London
in a racist attack in 1993. most of his
Killers have never faced Justice
baroness Doreen Lawrence says she'll
seek a review of the cps's decision
they've already agreed to fight in the
ring and now Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg are going head-to-head with
their social media acts meta launched
its direct rival to Twitter today
threads which has already attracted
millions of users and now Twitter is
threatening to take legal action its
owner tweeting tonight competition is
fine cheating is not Sky's Becky
cultural reports
give a billionaire a popular social
networking site and what you get well
another billionaire and his own
remarkably similar version of said
social networking site it's Elon Musk
versus Mark Zuckerberg Twitter versus
drumroll please threads aptly named for
a rival app and bearing a striking
resemblance to its main competitor you
can post text updates up to 500
characters long along with links and
photos and other users content appears
in your timeline I've got the Sky News
account up on Twitter and threads to
show you the likenesses so this is
Twitter this is threads look at the
layout and the way the text and video
appears
even the way that users can like comment
and retweet or repost is so very similar
and all this has got Elon Musk seriously
riled up with Twitter threatening to sue
Mark Zuckerberg's company meta over its
new app
meta actually tried out the name threads
for a different site in 2019. it didn't
look like this and it didn't really take
off but the brand has been recycled it
seems for disillusioned tweeters like
Emma Jane Palin an interior stylist
relying on social media to promote her
business I used to be on Twitter and I
used to love it and then I think it went
a little bit depressing and just a bit
kind of dark with threads just because
my audience from Instagram is obviously
coming over and it's nice to speak to
people in in more of a conversational
sense Elon Musk fired 80 of Twitter's
staff after he took over last year and
he made unpopular changes to the app
like drastically limiting the number of
tweets users can see so does threads
spell the end for a site hundreds of
millions of people use ultimately the
history of Technology shows that
consumers will flop to the the product
that they like the most and we've seen
this whether you take from Myspace in
the early days of Technology right
through to tick tock and Instagram use
this little shift with what they think
is the best product and I think we'll
probably see that in the social media
space right now as well
while being a big old copycat is not new
in the tech World Zuckerberg's latest
Venture is extremely well timed when it
comes to dissatisfaction with Twitter
and it looks like musk has already come
out fighting but threats alone are
unlikely to eradicate the competition
Becky Cottrell Sky News
to the tennis now and Andy Murray has
hit back in his match against Stefano
systematic the fifth seed won the first
set on a tie break but three-time Grand
Slam Champion Murray won the second in
yet another tie break Wimbledon has an
11 p.m curfew so if it's not completed
by then they'll come back tomorrow
being Brody beat world number four
Casper rude in a second round upset the
British number five fought back from two
sets to one down to win six four three
six four six six three six love in three
hours and 27 minutes Woody makes the
third round for the second year in a row
that wasn't the only British success
Katie Balter reached round a three with
a two sets to one win against Victoria
tomova the British number one reaches
round three for the second straight year
and is the only remaining British female
in the tournament
England got back in the game today
tearing through Australia in the third
test of the ashes it was in front of a
lively crowd at headingley who made
their feelings clear to the tourists our
Sports correspondent Rob Harris reports
listen for the Jazz
by Headley standards this was restrained
even with bitterness raging over
Australia's ashes conduct
England had a series to save
a first over dismissal the blistering
start needed
and this pace and precision
that wood was selected
[Applause]
two more wickets fell before lunch
no slip from Johnny bass those hands
delighting his home Yorkshire following
days after he was so contentiously
dismissed at Lords England's next
breakthrough came just before team
then the full hostility anticipated when
next to back was Alex Carey the
antagonist who stopped bairstow four
days earlier
who failed in Australia's afternoon
collapse as wood completed the five
Wicket Hall
[Applause]
not quite as emphatic when England
replied
with seven wickets remaining England
trail by 195.
there'd be no storms over sportsmanship
this time just some exhilarating Cricket
in a test England have given themselves
a chance of winning and they have to win
if they have any prospects are still
regaining the urn
pretty Lively uh which I think we all
enjoyed but it was it was in a good
humored England might win this test
match but over the whole series I think
it's it's Australia's overconfidence
England will hope turns out to be
premature Rob Harris Sky News headingley
Sky News at 10 coming up we'll take a
first look at tomorrow's newspapers in
the Press preview including this story
horror at the Tea Party on the front
page of the Metro as papers react to the
death of an 80 year old girl today
tonight we are going to be joined by the
contributing editor at Novara media Moya
Lothian McLean and the chief executive
of the total politics group Mark Wallace
who stay with us for me
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
amazing
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Sky News in just a moment the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive but first our
top stories an eight-year-old has been
killed and 16 people injured after a car
crashed into a primary school in
Southwest London the driver has been
arrested
evaluation leader has said The Afghani
progosian is back in Russia raising
questions about the deal that ended the
Mercury leaders short-lived Rebellion
the gunman who killed beautician Ellie
Edwards by opening fire on the
merseyside pub on Christmas Eve has been
convicted of murder her father branded
Connor Chapman a coward after the
verdict
[Music]
you are watching The Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the
contributing editor at Navara media Moya
Lothian McLean and the chief executive
of the total politics group Mark Wallace
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
School tea party horror headlines the
mirror following the tragic death of an
eight-year-old girl
the Metro also leads with a similar
headline
The Daily Mail shows a picture of the
car which crashed into the school while
reporting on the same story
and that story is also on the front of
the Sun
an exclusive in the eye reads the home
office has painted over Mickey Mouse
mural for children at an asylum Center
and says the immigration Minister has
described it as too welcoming
the guardian reports about the cabinet
office losing its bid to withhold Boris
Johnson's WhatsApp messages from the
covid-19 inquiry
The Daily Telegraph says the Archbishop
of Canterbury has backed trans students
following an ongoing series of free
speech rows at universities
the time zones that air controller
strikes that could disrupt up to a third
of all European summer flights risking
delays and cancellations
the financial times reports on the fall
of global stock markets after U.S
borrowing costs touched a 16-year high
and an etiquette faux pas The Daily Star
tells us we've been eating Weetabix the
wrong way
hmm a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
the contributing editor at Novara media
Moya Lothian McLean and the chief
executive of the total politics group
Mark Wallace welcome to you both and um
we start with this well very distressing
story it's on the front page of most of
the newspapers and this is the crash
that
um well culminated in the the loss of
life of an eight-year-old girl uh more
take us into this story
yeah so this happened just before 10 a.m
this morning really devastating at the
end of term uh it happened in Wimbledon
at an all-gar school called the study
prep school and the details exactly of
what happened at the moment at hazy the
report early reports say that there was
an alleged medical incident with the
driver of a Land Rover a woman her 40s
has been arrested on suspicion of death
by dangerous driving what we do know for
sure is at least 16 people were killed
when this Land Rover smashed into an end
of term tea party that's being held and
unfortunately one child just eight years
old was killed at the scene it's just
really devastating you know these
children are celebrating end of term
teachers parents and then something like
this that comes in the the aftershocks
are going to be going on for a very long
time
yes just to say that um 16 people were
treated at the scene and 10 were taken
to hospital and um as we said the
eight-year-old girl lost her life um but
just a dreadful Dreadful story mark
yes horrifying and you know by I I have
two um children of primary school age
and this is you know
sometimes there were you know it's a
cliche to say this every parent's worst
time now but but in this instance that's
entirely appropriate sadly I mean I I
only I have a couple of miles away from
where this instant who closing by chance
today I was at my younger son's end of
term celebration and you know they're
they're kind of end of term performance
and it is you know it's it's a kind of
it's meant to be a happy time it's the
start of the long summer and I am my my
heart and my thoughts go out to all the
families children and staff
um involves and affected by this
incident
exactly as much as we don't know exactly
what has happened yet we have um you
know unfortunately there are
occasionally uh instance I can even
become a serious incidents in the past
in the UK where there have been medical
issues and medical emergencies affecting
a driver for example we don't know what
led this to happen but what we do know
already a horrifying incident
it's the um randomness of of this um
story which is so shocking there's
nothing that that could have been done
to prevent it and we
um see on the front of the the mirror
they've got the police chief Claire
Kellen their um pictured and she
struggled um and fought back tears when
she addressed the the media that were
gathered outside
yeah that's really heart-rending footage
of parents at the scene crying and you
know parents also went past police calls
in order to give their children's
details to police officers to try and
make sure that their children were safe
but you're right with incidents like
this it is that total alignment of
random events that make them so
terrifying because people think well it
could happen any place anywhere and
there's absolutely nothing I could do to
stop this and I think that's why we'll
see on every single front page because
it has grabbed the fearful imagination
in such a way but the only sort of
I don't know relief that you can get
from this is the art they are very rare
you don't see something like that that's
happen on a regular basis which is why
it's such headline news but just
absolutely devastating I think the whole
of Southwest London's in shock tonight
yeah indeed let's move on now to some
politics
as is I want to do and have a look at
the guardian and this story Mark
ministers are being ordered to to hand
over unredacted um documents including
Boris Johnson's WhatsApp messages
notebooks and Diaries and this is to the
the covert inquiry and after losing that
legal challenge
indeed and you know given the amount of
coverage there's already been of some of
these legal and political battles around
the early the early stages of the code
inquiry it's striking that these are
indeed only the early stages and it's
quite a remarkable situation
um the government but also the cabinet
office has got itself into in choosing
to try to fight
um against this level of disclosure and
I think the fact is that you know it's
going to be extremely important for a
variety of reasons that this inquiry has
done clearly that it's done properly and
that it's done promptly
um it's very important obviously for uh
everyone who's whose lives were
affecting so many different ways
um by the handling of the pandemic to
know exactly what the truth was and what
was decided why how and when it's going
to be equally important to make sure
that actually there's a proper study of
um you know for this country's future
response to God forbid another pandemic
or other crises that there's a proper
study of what worked what didn't work
what could have gone better what was
learned and how and and how we can take
the best lessons to make sure that the
responses are improved in this country
your lessons from this country's
successes and failures and from those of
other countries
um in that context I find it very hard
to understand why it would be
contentious that there should be proper
and full disclosure of what was decided
and how I mean we already have seen um
in less organized ways large tracts of
government whatsapps WhatsApp messages
for example be released and you know
thinking thinking about someone's
spontaneous disclosure of all of my
Hancock's messages a few months ago
um as far as I can see them you know
Bobby Johnson himself doesn't seem to
have any objection to this all being
shared into peculiar battle to have
chosen to fight but now it's being
decided I I you know you would expect
full disclosure on the the states part
and then the inquiry can get on with its
job well Boy The Guardian is reporting
that government Insiders are saying
they'll comply with the ruling made by
the high court judges but they're
concerned that it's going to set a
precedent for further demands for
important documents and messages held by
serving ministers so they they think
it's the the thin edge of the wedge
God forbid there's a present set that
serving ministers should you know people
should have full transparency and access
to documents that uh let light into the
goings-on of the ruling of this country
I mean it's an absolutely bizarre
argument to make without surrounding
yourself in a real veneer of slaves
which this government has expertly done
during its several iterations now
um also something that seems to be
missing from discussion around this is
that the ruling says that Heather
Hallett who's heading up this inquiry
can hand back any material that is not
actually relevant so it's not like she's
gonna keep the entire unredacted batch
of documents if they're not relevant the
whole point is caster wide net find out
which documents are most relevant to
this inquiry keep those hand the others
back these are not going to be on
display for all and thunder we're not
leaking the nation's secrets for
everyone to read this is specifically so
we can find out what was going on during
the governance of the country
um when the cover pandemic was ravaging
people hospitals as Care Homes Etc what
ministers are saying what the plans were
in place and as Mark says how we can
prevent that again it seems to be a very
no smoke without fire situation if
there's such an effort to hide exactly
what was being said who was saying it
and what was being decided I would
imagine there is a reason for that but
we will find out because now the court
has ruled that the unredacted documents
have to be passed over and I think it's
also worth noting these are not just
Boris for instance WhatsApp so you know
there's Diaries there's notebooks it's a
whole uh Cornucopia of
um evidence that should be used in this
aquarium full is submitted and it's just
a terrible look once again for the
government to be trying to obscure
access to that Mark you want to come in
quickly
yes I think it's interesting that this
isn't just a government legal battle
it's also the cabin officer's choice to
fight this legal battle and that I do
think suggests that they they do think
that it's part of a wider
um question of what level of disclosure
at what date should happen to affect
decision making we obviously have in
some cases cabinet documents get locked
away for decades but there is quite a
split personality within government and
within parts of the Civil Service about
what should be private and what should
be public we all know that politicians
and Indie journalists all read an awful
lot of their correspondence on WhatsApp
because it's encrypted and secure and at
the same time half of those politicians
and officials turn around and try to do
things like Banning end-to-end
encryption so there's a lot of elements
of Westminster and Whitehall I haven't
really made up their mind on one
consistent approach on this
a topic which gets a lot of people um
quite angry and but this is surprising
secure starmer um saying it's right to
raise concern about Sadiq Khan's Euless
expansion
well I think this is it's important to
note that uh this is a telegraph
reported story so it's a telegraph slant
on this particular story what his time
actually said was he was asked about a
particular candidate called Danny Beals
who's the Labor's candidate in the
upcoming Uxbridge and South America slip
election now that Boris Johnson has
bombastically stood down and you know
Danny bills wants to delay the extension
of the ulo scheme what Kirsten actually
said what he's rightly raising concern
on behalf of what he hopes will be his
constituents in relation to you as
because we understand the impact
financially however he then went on to
contextualize this and say you know
there is a legal requirement to deal
with air pollution it's not just a
political Choice it's made the abstract
U.S was first introduced by toy Mayer um
it's been used by a part of political 2
tool and he says but he's trying to
defend Danny Beals in sticking up for
what he says are the rights of his
constituents so it was actually a very
non-answer that Kirsten gave which is
quite typical Starman you know
politicking um but the telegraph read
into it what they wanted to read into it
because the telegrapher not that like
big fans of you there's repeatedly
well some might say possibly starma so
you think he's been misrepresented
um for the moment Moya and uh Mark we
are going to take a break stay right
where you are and when we come back
we'll be discussing the report on the
front of the Guardian which reads
Germany failed to listen to warnings on
Russia stay with us if you can
foreign
[Music]
working on AI to help do my job so
building things that could help with
genetics research and Neuroscience
research and used alongside experts it
can be incredibly helpful the danger
that I see at the moment is the fact
that we're using things like generative
AI to create things that we can't fact
check for ourselves and that's where the
experts in fact checking I.E journalists
are going to be more important than ever
so I'm more worried about there not
being enough money to pay for skilled
journalists with an expert beat who can
check what's coming out of these models
because skills journalists with an
expert beat be AI well we could yeah we
could design AI models to automate it
you know do automated fact checking of
of Articles and then you get into some
kind of weird Battle of AIS with AIS
talking to each other which I do worry a
bit about the uh the fact that these AIS
can often hallucinate uh just make up
facts that are not that are not uh
Tethered to reality in in any way but I
do see um uh at the moment that AI could
be a really useful productivity tool for
for journalists like me uh can send an
article in uh say do you think paragraph
four has a particularly strong argument
and it says well maybe you want to add a
bit more evidence there and and can kind
of be a little something isn't it as
opposed to actually taking over your job
well yeah I think um you know
the word computer that used to be a
person right you used to be a person who
did calculations and now uh obviously we
think of a computer as something
completely automated and it's very you
know a completely different uh
understanding of what that word means
maybe AI at the moment is a bit like uh
you know uh that sort of task it
replaces a human uh um who used to do
that sort of task and uh in future we'll
just see some certain tasks subbing
they're just done automatically and
that's just part of how the world works
and intelligence in the human sense and
in the animal sense comes from billions
of years of evolution of trying to solve
for you know finding somebody to
reproduce with not to actually find a
point on it and avoiding being eaten and
finding things to eat computers don't
care about any of that so what we
consider to be machine intelligence is
usually about trying to get machines to
do something that we would find useful
that's why I'm not too scared about the
idea of some kind of AI apocalypse
because it would require a bad actor a
malevolent person to say I want this
machine to help me do a terrible thing
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me the contributing
editor at Novara media Moya Lothian
McLean and the chief executive of the
total politics group Mark Wallace let's
have a look at the um Metro uh first of
all we're going to go inside the Metro
this is on page 13.
um picture there Evgeni pagosian Wagner
head still in Russia as a raid on home
uncovers disguises and we have those
bizarre
um pictures I don't know if you saw them
in the reports that we've been running
today of uh wigs and all sorts in his um
his closet but clearly as declared by
lukashenka he's not in Belarus mark
well I mean we're in the unusual
um situation in the normal world and the
perfectly common situation in putanist
politics of listening to One career liar
um tell something that contradicts the
claims of another career liar about
their mutually employed welcome who's on
the run so nobody knows if Luka shank is
telling the truth because he spent
decades telling lies about everything so
um the the interesting thing here is
that it all continues to throw into
doubt the more we hear about this
exactly what condition Putin's regime is
in exactly what the status of the
falconer group and the many thousands of
war criminals who who make up its ranks
and Leadership
um is and exactly what the outcome of
that supposed deal was
um what's quite fascinating is that even
you know in this notoriously closed uh
regime that deals with its internal
opponent's internal fallings out
um very bluntly where you tend to only
find the conclusion of a dispute when
somebody disappears goes to prison or
die
um and normally other suspicious
circumstances this is so much of this is
taking place in public and there is such
a lack of
um closed in the normal internal kind of
message discipline that in itself is
interesting and it shows quite how much
you know hint at how much turmoil I must
continue to be inside the Kremlin and
its allies
um the political setup and Moya it is
fascinating because you really don't
know exactly what's happening I mean we
don't even know if progression ever made
it to Belarus at all um and whether he's
been in Russia this this whole time
very much so it's like Mark says we're
essentially dealing with he said he
smells scraps that are coming out via
unofficial sources that would usually
unlock plus the official propaganda
that's coming out of Russia you know
this raid on progression's house this
attempt to really just credit him
further by showing humiliating
items a giant hammer that says for use
in negotiations the The Spoils of hubris
now brought low and then you've got the
koshenko saying oh well you know maybe
he's going to go back to Moscow tomorrow
and uh but if you think he's going to be
whacked uh Putin would never do that
he's not going to be killed completely
unreliable completely unriable we won't
know what's going to have to progression
until we see what happens to pagosian
but I think as Marxist the key thing
here is the sort of lack of discipline
we're seeing there's been really high
ranking um Generals in the Russian army
they've been detained for their Wagner
sympathies and you're also seeing you
know there was there was a large Mutiny
that happened so what happens to all the
soldiers that were involved in that if
Putin doesn't as like really puts it
whack progosian what does that say about
his level of control over an internal
discipline that hasn't previously been
airtight it's it's a really fascinating
time but again we do not have solid
information about any of this so we're
all just watching it as it unfolds I
think we'll know what's happening when
it's happened uh basically I think um
we've just got time to talk about uh
threads versus Twitter take us into this
story Mark what's happening
well you know I think if you give it a
few more months everyone will be on
about 45 different kind of Twitter
killer apps but after Twitter's recent
outage where Elon Musk seems to have
mismanaged a game of chicken with Google
for their data storage he had to stop
users being able to view his unlimited
numbers and unlimited tweets as people
are used to
um Mark Zuckerberg has chosen has chosen
to make his move at a very opposite time
they've launched threads it looks a lot
like
um Twitter used to look 10 years ago it
feels a lot like Facebook you said 15
years ago actually
um uh but he's taken his moment and
they've I think this is the record by a
long talk for a new social platform
getting 10 million users and it seems
like yeah I'm on there so do go and
follow me